évoluer faire plaisir
et ça vous avez ça
alors là ça c'est incroyable ça
alors le journaliste Hugo Clément vient
aussi de sortir avec son nouveau média
en ligne va qui time longue enquête sur
pierre lata et vos méthodes dans cette
enquête plusieurs témoignages vous
accusent un ancien responsable animée
revient sur une publicité pour un parfum
que tout le monde a vu il y a une petite
chouette de Pierre Cadillac dans cette
publicité et ils disent qu'elle serait
morte de faim on va voir tout ça et
après vous allez répondre à toutes les
accusations bien sur le tournage de Nina
Ricci moi j'ai vu une chouette harpon
mourir
on a fait le tournage ce qui vit à peu
près trois jours pas les retours la
chouette n'a pas mangé dans le milieu du
dressage de pas donner à manger un
animal ça c'est courant par contre
Cadillac lui et n'hésitez pas d'affamer
ses animaux quand on s'est aperçu
qu'elle commençait à aller mal qu'on
avait donné un poussin mais c'est trop
tard elle est morte le lendemain
qu'est-ce que vous répondez à
Saint-Pierre
on commence par quoi alors déjà le règle
l'aigle chez nous il y a 350 animaux
mais ces animaux qui vivent chez nous
sont apprivoisées dressés pour les
tournages de films et sont extrêmement
familiers ce sont des animaux que l'on a
préparé nous-mêmes depuis leur plus
jeune âge et avec lesquels on a une
excellente relation
il se trouve qu'une partie de ces
animaux sont des amis c'est le cas de
cet aigle sont des animaux que l'on nous
confie que l'on donne que l'on met chez
nous parce qu'ils ont des problèmes
alors par exemple bon je crois que tout
le monde a vu Cyril je crois que il faut
savoir c'est que cet aigle par exemple à
passer sa vie dans plusieurs parcs et
tous les parcs dans lesquels il se
trouvaient il est né en captivité ont eu
des problèmes il est très agressif parce
qu'il a été mal élevé il a été levé et
alors qu'il était tout petit et qu'il
avait été élevé ou à la sortie de l'oeuf
par l'homme ce qu'il ne faut jamais
faire d'accord parce que un animal que
vous sortez
des sa naissance de des parents c'est
une erreur souvent l'animal après se
prendre pour un être humain et en
comportant avec vous comme il aurait
avec ses confrères c'est qu'on génère
quand son bébé ils sont très mignons
mais arrivé à l'âge adulte il se dit
qu'est-ce que tu fais sur mon territoire
et vous agresse cet aigle a été confié
par un parc le directeur m'a dit écoutez
il va arracher la joue d'un fauconnier
il veut essayer de le faire voler en
liberté et je me suis retrouvé avec un
oiseau que j'ai mis avec parce que je
suis un spécialiste de la reproduction
des aigles depuis mon plus jeune âge
j'élève des aigles j'avais déjà 15 ans
que je partais en mes Pyrénées natales
et tout seul dans la montagne je passais
une semaine mon père me laisser dans un
petit chemin elle me disait pierre même
endroit même heure dans une semaine et
je passais une semaine dans la montagne
avec mon ex qui volait et qui
m'attrapait des proies et qui me faisait
manger j'avais quand même un sac à dos
avec une boîte de quelques boîtes de
conserve au cas où on serait bro mais
voilà j'ai eu une vie et l'aigle fait
partie de ma vie et cet oiseau est-ce
que les gens ont envoyé
par cette image je le comprends pourquoi
vous avez fait ça en fait vous en danger
parce que c'est un oiseau qui j'ai mis
d'abord comme on me l'a confié pour le
faire reproduire d'accord on produit
beaucoup de rapaces activités je
reproduis des aigles que je relâche dans
le milieu naturel il y a un aigle qui
vole à côté de Fontainebleau sur une une
zone sensible où il y a beaucoup d'eau
c'est un aigle pêcheur qui a disparu de
France qui s'appelle le pigargue à queue
blanche cet oiseau je l'ai réintroduit
je donne des vautours pour les
réintroduire en les Balkans d'où ils ont
disparu et je fais beaucoup d'actions la
liste est très longue on va pas pouvoir
avoir le temps je crains de pouvoir
l'évoquer aujourd'hui mais cet aigle lui
n'est pas né chez moi a été mal élevé ne
peut pas reproduire parce qu'on l'a mis
avec une avec je l'ai mis avec un mâle
chez moi il a ici à plusieurs reprises
tué le mal et un lundi matin mais là il
essayait de vous attaquer qu'est-ce qui
se passe là je vous explique j'en ai
pour deux secondes j'ai dit aux
stagiaire qui était présent voilà
c'était que je leur ai raconté ce que je
vous dis il ne peut pas voler un liberté
parce qu'il attaque les hommes on ne
peut pas le faire reproduire parce qu'il
tue les mal c'est un oiseau qui est très
perturbé on va quand même essayer de le
faire voler je suis Fauconnier plage de
12 ans de le familiariser d'arriver à
l'apaiser et de le faire voler je l'ai
depuis 5 minutes sur ma main il m'a
flingué un coup de crâne un coup de bec
sur le cuir chevelu en fait qui n'est
plus chevelu il m'a donné un coup de un
coup d'elle avec le coude qui est très
dur il peut vous ouvrir l'arcade sur la
le visage on ne le voit pas et on le
voit sur la vidéo il m'attrape ma main
et là je me dis il faut faire quelque
chose j'essaye de le familiariser alors
je me suis dit il faut faire quelque
chose spontanément
œil pour œil Peque pour bec je lui mets
une gifle alors cet oiseau après je suis
allé m'asseoir on ne va pas l'image est
sorti de son contexte les réseaux
sociaux c'est le tribunal nord-coréen on
ne peut pas défendre on se retrouve avec
des gens qui vous agressent alors que je
fais finalement ça pour son bien ça peut
paraître paradoxal et je comprends que
ça choque des gens mais que faire de cet
oiseau il peut pas reproduire il ne peut
pas voler il va pas passer 40 ans de sa
vie dans une volière tout seul alors je
me suis dit tu vas essayer et
spontanément j'ai répliqué à son attaque
on le voit très bien m'attraper la main
avec le B je pense que il faut savoir
que chez nous j'ai arrêté tout ça parce
que je suis en train de transformer mon
parc en temps de redressement on m'amène
des malinois des chiens malinois qui ont
mordu parce que les gens sont dépassés
par ces chiens alors je les ai
l'association les mains chez moi je les
héberge je les nourris je nettoie on
entretien ces chiens et avec le concours
même de la
la canine on essaie de les réhabiliter
de les apaiser c'est génial il a passé
trois ans dans une grange et le type le
nourrissait avec une poulie bon c'était
un chat qui mordait les barreaux quand
il nous voyaient voilà les actions que
je mène et la liste est longue voilà
mais Pierre là vous nous parlez de votre
amour des animaux de l'aigle moi je veux
bien mais la très clairement vous n'êtes
pas en danger il y a eu un coup sur
votre cuir chevelu vous frappez
violemment un aigle que vous savez
difficile puisque c'est pour ça qu'on
vous le confie tous les animaux
difficiles comme ça vous les tabassez de
cette manière c'est extrêmement choquant
l'image est d'une chance incroyable je
suis d'accord avec vous c'est pour ça
que je suis là que je suis pierre il
faut que tu t'expliques tu n'es pas un
[ __ ] tu aimes les animaux et je fais
énormément d'actions je viens de faire
depuis cet incident un film publicitaire
pour l'incident vous l'avez pas
la vidéo je la soupçonne d'être accéléré
parce que on le voit de façon l'aigle
faire des il se redresse il n'est pas du
tout blessé il n'est pas assommé il est
tout à fait en pleine possession de ses
moyens il s'est jeté en arrière parce
qu'on me l'a dit il a peut-être pris
d'autres baffes avant moi et du coup
c'est un oiseau oui je sais alors
qu'est-ce qu'on fait donnez-moi la
recette alors je laisse cet oiseau je le
tout seul dans une volière à peu près en
40 ans plus de vie sociale on va voir
juste une autre c'est compliqué c'est
énormément parler pierre et vous allez
Géraldine va donner son avis aussi il y
a aussi cette histoire de de singe il
regardait
directement et j'ai vu de mes yeux
pierre frappé et être violent plusieurs
fois avec beaucoup d'animaux du parc il
y a aucun de zania une singe Mago
c'était vraiment une singe qui était
vraiment mignonne et bien dressée et un
jour il a vraiment perdu son calme et il
a tabassé un coup de poing en plein
visage tout le monde hurlait on le
supplie et d'arrêter et quand il a enfin
fini elle était elle était défigurée
elle était en sang elle lui avait
vraiment éclaté le visage quoi j'ai pris
des photos le jour qui ont suivi des
photos voilà de son visage complètement
rempli d'hématome de ses yeux qui avait
des cocards
alors Géraldine non je vous écoute
monsieur moi effectivement là c'est un
témoignage anonyme donc ces paroles
contre parole effectivement l'aigle bah
en fait j'ai tendance à vous croire en
fait c'est à dire qu'est-ce qu'on fait
de cette aigle là comment on fait pour
le réhabiliter j'imagine que vous
répondez alors effectivement l'image
comme ça couper dans le contexte elle
est très violente et je comprends que ça
voilà qu'on soit ému et qu'on soit
perturbé mais j'ai moi j'ai envie de
vous de vous croire en fait ce soir
quand vous venez sur plateau comme ça
vous avez que des coups à prendre à
venir ici malgré tout parce que vous
êtes quelqu'un qui maltraitait les
animaux et on monte ça en boucle et tout
donc franchement je voilà je j'ai envie
de vous faire confiance mais Jean-Marie
moi je connais bien pierre on fait
quelques films ensemble et dans le dans
presque 100% des cas pierre fonctionne
avec amour et avec tendresse avec les
animaux il m'a fait mes aigles au Stade
de France
52000 personnes qui hurlent il faut
savoir commander le truc tous des
animaux obéit une question de
d'éducation je l'ai vu le fils de
Laurent Baffie monté sur un
ours qu'il avait amené pierre à
l'anniversaire de du petit il est monté
sur un ours il faut savoir qu'un ours il
te met un coup de patte dans la gueule
il t'arrache la tête mais il est non
seulement il est courageux mais il a
confiance et surtout il désire d'abord
rassurer l'animal pour que l'animal soit
le mieux possible et il sait donner une
certaine éducation animaux pour qu'il
fasse des trucs formidables Delphine et
la plus qui est la plus remontée en
règle générale et c'est la même chose
pour pour les chiens et donc les animaux
sauvages aussi il y a deux manières de
d'éduquer en fait soit l'éducation
positive ou soit par la contrainte donc
moi j'estime que quand on donne pas à
manger un animal sur plusieurs jours
effectivement on arrive on arrive à ces
fins mais on arrive aussi donc
effectivement donc la chouette est morte
ça on est d'accord la chouette est morte
pour Nina Ricci si vous me permettez de
répondre cette
avec le monsieur qui me dénonce c'est
extravagant cet homme a fait acheminer
deux loups et une chouette un Roumanie
pour le tournage au retour après le
tournage bien dit et j'ai le témoignage
d'une jeune fille qui était dans la
véhicule moi je suis rentré en avion et
je leur ai dit voilà vous devez
arrêterez deux fois le matin et le soir
le matin et le soir du deuxième jour du
voyage et vous nourrirez la chouette ce
monsieur était extrêmement prêché pour
rentrer le résultat c'est qu'il ne s'est
pas arrêté une fois pour nourrir la
chouette et quand elle est arrivée elle
était très faible et cette chouette est
morte et ce monsieur a quitté mon
entreprise mon activité voilà la réalité
c'est extravagant que ce soit lui qui
dénonce cette chouette alors que c'est
lui qui l'a pas nourri monsieur
bon dire la vérité et pas pour autant
aussi de dire quand on manipule les
animaux et et vous manipuler les
le coca du singe donc il s'est fait le
coca tout seul ou je peux m'expliquer
allez il y a trois animaux qui viennent
d'être évoqué pour lesquels j'ai mené
des actions et j'ai les ai recueillis ce
singe la police j'étais quasiment
réquisitionné comme ça arrive souvent et
la police avec les services vétérinaires
mondiaux il faut que nous accompagner on
doit saisir un singe dans une banlieue
je ne citerai pas laquelle c'est un
singe noir africain qui a été amené
clandestinement en France et il est dans
un appartement c'est un chien en bois de
disparition dans son milieu naturel qui
a donc été prélevé dans le milieu
naturel vous devez venir parce que nous
on ne sera pas quoi faire de ce singe
donc j'ai accompagné la police m'a mis
des dugasseur du scotch sur les plaques
d'immatriculation du véhicule pour qu'on
ne me reconnaisse pas et puisse pas
m'identifier et me retrouver j'ai
moi-même changé le nom de ce singe et je
me suis retrouvé avec la police au bas
d'un immeuble et nous avons d'ailleurs
nous avons bon bref pour faire court on
a récupéré ce singe qui avait été qui
avait des couches culottes et qui
mangeaient du McDonald's et je peux vous
dire c'est pas son régime alimentaire
c'est un animal qui a été sûrement très
mal entretenu et qui était qui a été
tracassé agacée qui est quand même
compliqué à gérer voilà et moi ce sage
effectivement un jour il a attaqué les
soigneurs les soigneurs et la personne
qui me dénonce je sais qui c'est elle a
bosse pas se cacher c'est notre
secrétaire qui s'appelle Catherine
Bréart et je peux vous dire que je lui
ai dit madame je vous descends d'aller
avec ce singe parce que il vous épouille
et puis tout d'un coup il va vous
regarder il va vous provoquer c'est la
vie les singes entre eux on dirait des
lois sociales très complexes et souvent
très violentes mais ne dites pas que
vous faites la conservation en fait
parce que vous avez pas de sanctuaire
vous êtes quelqu'un qui vous fait de
l'argent avec les animaux ou je fais de
l'argent avec ce c'est moi qui
l'entretiens qui paye des gens pour le
nourrir et pour le nettoyer et je ne
vous laisse pas me dire ça parce que pas
du tout en aucun cas madame je vous dis
la vérité ce singe ne me rapporte de
l'argent il est là il est là uniquement
pour un pour parce qu'on ne sait pas où
le mettre alors pour finir l'histoire de
ce singe j'ai été dans un parc animalier
à grammat dans le Lot chercher un couple
de la même famille pour qu'il soit pas
tout seul je les ai ramenés moi j'ai mis
ensemble et ça s'est mal terminé ils
l'ont attaqué parce qu'il n'a pas les
codes sociaux pour vivre avec des singes
cet animal et du coup Florence Olivet
courtois notre vétérinaire l'a opéré
avec des plaies des morsures de 10 cm
des des plaies de 10 cm dans sur son
corps on l'a soigné et tout ça je le
fais à mes frais alors moi personne je
m'appelle pas Hugo Clément bonjour les
tournages Jean-Marie tu l'as vu il a été
adorable avec les animaux devant
je vous accuse pas j'étais je connais
pas le singe la chouette je vous accuse
pas je connais pas je regarde juste ça
quand vous lui mettez c'est pas une gif
c'est une patate vous le mettez une
droite et vous dites alors et celle-là
tu l'as vu ça là merde alors c'est
incroyable ça c'est pas une manière
d'élever ça voilà
on me demande de parler je parle si
c'est un aigle qui a été élevé par des
hommes et qu'on peut pas rééduquer etc
pourquoi vous l'avez pris pourquoi vous
le donnez pas quelqu'un d'autre pourquoi
vous le prenez pourquoi vous prenez pour
un justicier pour rééduquer un aigle
pour lui mettre des patates dans la
bouche comme ça ça sert à rien en fait
il a l'espoir de le dresser de le
remettre comme ça
il faut vous dire vu personne ne va rien
moi je préfère qu'il soit tout seul qui
a prendre des droites comme ça attacher
vous les connaissez pas il y a plein
d'animaux des fois que tu peux pas
réadapter qu'il faut placer dans des
centres avec des gens qui vont s'en
occuper mais comme ça non non ils vont
pas s'en occuper
vous vouliez faire du cinéma avec cette
technique
je le reproduis cette espèce le pigargue
à tête blanche cette année en 2022 j'en
ai eu 7 jeunes et les miens sont élevés
par les parents normalement et quand ils
sont adultes je les attrape je les ai
adorable alors
c'est magnifique
et là c'est quand même une sacrée preuve
bien sûr
exactement
c'est l'éducation alors qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez moi je trouve que vous
êtes trop dur avec Pierre cadet parce
qu'il fait partie d'un système dont on a
tous été acteurs on sait que pendant des
années il y a eu des animaux dans les
cirques dans les films ça fait des
années vous êtes dansez votre métier et
ça choqué personne à l'époque donc là
c'est facile oui ce métier il est en
train d'évoluer mais on peut pas lui
tomber dessus en disant que c'est
quelqu'un qui maltraitent les animaux
on n'a jamais tabasser des chiens on n'a
jamais vu les chiens ça ça vous choquait
pas à l'époque d'aller voir des films
avec des animaux de regarder ses
publicités donc voilà et le meilleur
exemple effectivement c'est fort Boyard
avant il y avait des tiques ça choqué
personne et Delphine toi tu y étais
aujourd'hui on les a retiré parce que la
société voulue donc le son métier évolue
c'est très bien les concepts sur lui
avec des témoignages anonymes comme
c'était un nom du cinéma vous le
défendez pas comme ça soyez honnêtes
tous ceux qui regardez juste
derrière vous voyez un mec qui vient
demain qui met une patate comme ça à un
aigle vous allez tous
en même temps quoi vraiment non moi je
dis que c'est parce que ce monsieur là
il est respectable il y a pas de
problème il fait bien son travail il y a
pas de problème je le connais pas tu
l'as vu toi Jean-Marie sur un tournage
avec 100 personnes il est adorable je
dis juste que il a une espèce de carte
là ce soir s'il est pas dans le cinéma
personne ne défend comme ça si on prend
un homme comme ça pareil
moi je dis que voilà c'est ce que je
pense moi je peux peut-être monsieur
parce qu'en fait vous savez les gens
sont choqués c'est normal c'est normal
moi en fait vous savez il y a un vieux
proverbe qui dit qui aime bien châtie
bien ces animaux c'est ma vie cet oiseau
j'avais l'intention d'arriver à faire je
me suis cru plus fort que le roquefort
les quatre parts qu'ils ont qui ont
dégagé ce sont refilé il a fini chez moi
je me suis dit tu ne peux pas laisser
spaso toute sa vie parce qu'ils ont
besoin d'avoir des lois sociaux des
règles sociales une vie sociale vous
êtes trop plus fort que le Roxan
surtout pas ce soir surtout pas de souci
[Musique]
témoigné contre vous plus pourquoi plus
pourquoi mais moi aussi il y a 18
personnes qui témoin
14 millions donc ton témoigne sur nous
c'est faux quand on démarre sur lui
c'est vrai pas du tout là j'ai les faits
j'ai tous les faits à chaque fois
les personnages c'est des témoignages
anonyme parce que c'est des témoignages
est-ce que c'est des témoignages tu peux
lui parler
avec toi il y a toujours deux poids de
mesure
des témoignages anonymes ici sur toi tu
vas voir tu vas tous les soirs en bois
de Boulogne avec l'autre calme-toi non
mais je te le dis c'est insupportable
ils ont fait un espèce de Mediapart des
végan là où ils font des témoignages
anonymes c'est insupportable alors ces
gens-là je suis sûr que c'était les
premiers aller dans des cirques il y a
quelques années applaudir des tiques qui
se faisait défoncer donc soyez un peu
droit dans vos bots le métier il évolue
comme la société
en regardant la vidéo en entier le début
la fin la bonne vitesse et tout ça je
vais m'asseoir avec l'oiseau et que je
le caresse longuement on le montre pas
ça et moi je sais pas comment on fait
pour donc tu les Aigles donc en fait il
y a que vous qui pouvez nous expliquer
4 secondes là évidemment que ça allait
extrêmement violent mais c'est une
histoire que vous auriez battu ce serait
est un animal qui n'a pas du tout
été brutalisé jamais c'est une
prisonnière
moi ce que je vois au juge la vidéo là
c'est tout là on va arrêter de parler
j'ai vu si j'ai vu ça non mais les gars
il a il a fait du toboggan sur le coup
d'une girafe arrêtez les gars et voilà
on regarde ça on juge ça on va avoir on
jusqu'au bois et la tête
exactement
je tiens à dire je participe à des
gracieusement à des films pour
publicitaires pour la SPA à des films
publiés bien sûr pour la 30 Millions
d'Amis c'est pas une je viens de faire
un film sur la vie de Brigitte Bardot
quand même les tout le monde savait
l'histoire de cet aigle je me suis
expliqué moi quand même pris et je n'ai
je pense que je suis payable
je connais il fait de la pub pour des
régimes il a pas perdu 1 kg de 3
[Applaudissements]